When I was very young like around 13
years old I used to travel
to San Diego and Los Angeles.
And I realized and I noticed there that the air pollution was
horrendous at the time. And I thought well why should people live like this?
So I learned about climate and air
pollution in more detail.
And then I just dedicated my career so this is what I want to do. I want to understand
and solve large-scale problems of air pollution and climate.
For the last 20 years I've been looking at both the problems and the solutions.
But even the last five years
it's been more focus on the solutions because we really need to solve the problems at this point.
With this course,
we'll learn how it's possible to solve these major problems that have not been solved before
including air pollution which kills
seven million people per year.
We'll learn how to eliminate air pollution
entirely from the face of the earth.
We'll learn how to eliminate the
emissions associated with global warming,
which will eventually result in
temperatures stabilizing and coming back
to pre-industrial time temperatures of
the earth. And we will eliminate global
insecurities of energy resources which
arise due to the limited availability of
fossil fuels and their decreasing
availability over time.
So those who are
interested in transitioning - those
companies, those individuals, and also
policymakers who want to pass laws - to
try to effect a transition not only
cost-effectively but also equitably,
would be interested in taking this course.
So students in this course will
not only learn the details about what's
needed to go to 100% clean renewable
energy. But they will also be given
information about what policies are
available to do this, and and what's been
done so far. You know the bottom line is
we need to combine ... since we're
electrifying all energy sectors we're
really a combining electricity, heating,
cooling, industry, transportation - we're
electrifying those sectors.
And we can use a combination of not only
renewable resources, but electricity storage,
heat storage, cold storage, some
hydrogen storage, also what's called
demand response. These techniques and
technologies are discussed in this
course and basically how to keep the
grid stable is something that hopefully
you'll be more confident about after
taking the class.
This skill is very
important today because there are many
jobs that require an understanding of a
clean renewable energy system. There are over 200 companies in the world
including 8 out of the 10 biggest
companies of the world that have
committed to 100% clean renewable energy. Who is going to guide these companies
I'm optimistic we can solve these
problems. And actually having changed my
own life by building a completely
renewable home with no gas. Just uses
electricity with heat pumps, induction
cooktop stove, electric cars, and
generates more electricity than it uses
in the annual average. I know that it's
possible not only do this on a local
scale but also on a large scale. And this
is maybe passionate since I feel like I
understand the issues quite well now. I
feel like the solutions are also at our
at hand. And so it's very important to
provide that information to others to
help solve this large-scale problem that
affects humanity.